l'objectif de cette manifestation c'est
la prise de contact en premier lieu le
réseautage et que tout cet ensemble de
choses puisse permettre de réaliser des
contrats d'avoir du business c'est la
cas rubiales e-business cruz donc les
chefs d'entreprise peuvent arriver à
avoir des retours très concret et qu'il
puisse enfin se développer sur la carène
la première édition qui s'est déroulée
cette année en février 2019
effectivement a eu des retours très
positifs puisque nous avons une
entreprise de la guadeloupe qui a
proposé son sucre et qui a eu des
retours qui sont en train de se
concrétiser donc nous suivons avec
attention l'évolution des des relations
qui ont été établis et puis en
martinique nous avons également deux
entreprises qui ont eu des retours très
concret
l'une dans la peinture qui est en train
de signer qui est en train d'établir le
contrat en vue de signature et la
joaillerie
nous avons également des contacts qui
ont été pris au niveau institutionnel
pour la suite
au niveau immobilier au niveau financier
au niveau implantations d'entreprises
donc ce sont vraiment des choses qui ont
qui se sont concrétisés par des ce qu'on
souhaitait par des contacts par des
actions par des contrats et par du
business lors de la première édition
nous étions une quarantaine de
participants là nous visons entre 70 et
80 personnes et à minima une soixantaine
de chefs d'entreprise donc les contacts
sont déjà établis avec les îles du nord
où nous allons tortola saint kitts
dominique antigua 5 martin et
édition se présente plutôt bien nous
avons de bons retours
le soutien des ccf les conseillers du
commerce extérieur de france des
chambres de commerce de la caribéenne
exporte donc vraiment nous nous sommes
très confiants l'ambassadeur de france a
bien compris l'intérêt de cette
manifestation dont qu'ils soutiennent la
soutient et nous aide à mettre en place
les différents rendez vous que nous
serons amenés à apprendre pour les
entreprises on est là pour permettre aux
chefs d'entreprise d'aller à l'encontre
des autres chefs d'entreprises des
institutions des autres il est de faire
des échanges de discuter le toujours
gardé le contact
sur le bateau il y aura des séminaires
des conférences avec la complicité de
notre avocat d'affaires meutre
jean-claude beaujour le début de cette
première manifestation je ne dirais pas
je ne citerai pas de noms mais on nous a
pas pris véritablement sérieux on nous a
rayonné on nous a dit ah oui nous aller
faire une croisière s'amuse
et dieu merci heureusement que nous
avons eu des interventions des
témoignages des premiers pionniers de je
dirais de cette belle croisière qui ont
su démontrer que cette croisière n'était
pas spécialement dédié à l'amusement